we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. here's something really funny.
There's a really funny question in this voicemail
where the answer might actually surprise you.
Hey David, this is Dave [inaudible].
I have a question for you.
Do you think Stephen Miller will get fired
on his, uh, fairy owl white nationalist views?
Because how can they coexist with the very
religious Jared Kushner and a Pharmaca Trump?
How could those two coexist?
Well, they do and no, I would be shocked.
So what the call is referring to is that a
whole bunch of thinly veiled and more overt
white nationalists emails and sensibilities
were revealed.
Um, on the behalf of Trump advisor, Stephen
Miller, who does Trump policy advising, I
think maybe he does some speech writing as
well.
Who knows what he's doing at this point.
And the question is, well, hold on a second.
White nationalism is not compatible.
For example, with Judaism, Jared Kushner,
Kushner is Jewish.
Trump's daughter, Ivanka Trump converted to
Judaism.
Stephen Miller himself is Jewish.
Put all of that aside because that doesn't
matter.
You don't get fired in the Trump administration
for having white nationalist leanings if anything,
you get promoted.
So no, I don't believe at all that Stephen
Miller is going to be fired for the fact that
these emails have been leaked.
And in fact the defense from anybody who's
commented about it has been, listen, these
emails are years and years old.
I believe to some degree they were known about
although not to the full scope that they exist,
so no, I don't believe there will be any repercussions
for Stephen Miller for being so tied in with
white nationalist ideas.
I believe that he will persist and he is going
to do just fine.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We will talk about something good is happening
in California.
They're cracking down on fracking and I'm
going to tell you how and I'm going to tell
you whether this is happening in other States
and what the path forward maybe could be.
When it comes to fracking.
We will talk about a very bizarre case of
a husband and wife who were both topless in
their own homes, but the wife was charged
with lewdness.
It is another one of these very weird stories,
but it does have a sort of important underlying
legal question associated with it.
We also will talk about a staffing change
that is absolutely freaking out, homeless
advocates, and it relates to the Trump administration
policy towards the homeless.
It is something we've talked about on the
program many times before and we will deal
with all of that on today's bonus show.
Two ways to access the bonus show, become
a
member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
If you are waiting around for a membership
special, get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com
because on black Friday, the day after Thanksgiving,
next week, everybody on our newsletter, we'll
get an email about a crazy, crazy, obscene
membership discount.
It is so
low, low, low.
I am not even allowed to tell you what it
is.
That's a joke.
I'm just not going, but it's really good.
Speak to you on the bonus show.
Get on that newsletter, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].